you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in this video we'll take a look at a new
type of computing that are set to rival
the legendary quantum computer let's get
straight into it but first with a bit of
background understanding from phones and
tablets to pcs and gaming consoles to
supercomputers and smartwatches
computers are everywhere and you're
using one right now the thing is all of
these types of computers function the
same way these computers use machine
language fundamentally composed of ones
and zeroes to tell the computer what to
do like a written language the computer
reads word by word or instruction set by
instruction set until it understands
what to do it then executes it and moves
on to the next step we call this kind of
computer a classical computer so you
might be asking if my computer can only
do one task at a time how am i running
multiple things at once well in basic
terms a computer CPU is actually still
doing one thing at a time or one
instruction set at a time but switching
between them really quickly
roughly 2.5 billion times a second for a
2.5 gigahertz single-core a
single-threaded CPU so it actually just
seems like it's doing a lot of things at
once ok so that's all fine for running
software and things of that sort but
what if the requirements for your use
were much more than that what if you
needed vastly more competing horsepower
the kind that allows you to solve
complex equations with almost no bounds
things like cryptography or complex
simulations of things within our world
advanced mathematical models or just
many other applications that we couldn't
even dream of today these kind of
problems can be described and
categorized as taking exponentially more
time to solve with increasing complexity
classical computers can't do such things
very well
the closest thing that we've gotten to
is many classical computers slap
together and given the title of a
supercomputer what we need is a computer
that can actually solve many problems at
the same time what we need is
then called a parallel computer all
right so you might be thinking look I've
heard of this parallel computing thing
before wasn't that what quantum
computers were supposed to do this is
correct however the research is in the
groundbreaking experiment I'm about to
show you state that the quantum computer
hasn't been proved to be practical from
a fabrication and operational
perspective for example a quantum
computer has to be very close to
absolute zero in temperature to even
function these hurdles may be overcome
in the future but for now there needs to
be a better solution this is where the
bio-computer comes in of which a brand
new feasible solution has just been
discovered at Lund University in Sweden
the results have been published in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences the bio computing approach uses
less than 1% of the energy used by
current electronic transistors the
result can see the power of today's
supercomputers fit into the form factor
of a laptop without absurd amounts of
power and heat most of you know that
nano means very very small I'd like to
start by just saying how small and if
you imagine you take the whole earth and
reduce it enough to become as large as a
football so that's about 50 million
times smaller and then you imagine you
do the same thing one more time you take
the football and take it down another 20
or 50 million times then you are the
size of what you call a nanoparticle
something that is on this size range of
a few thousand atoms or so a ball of
material now why are we interested in
this the the main reason sometimes the
reason is that not making things small
that's just the point
so for example if you try to build
faster and more powerful computers
that's what you want you want to make
smaller transistors that you can pack
many of them onto a small space that can
talk quickly to each another and that's
the whole point so what exactly is the
solution as it turns out the solution
has been around for a very long time in
the form of a protein called myosin part
of our muscle tissue you're actually
using myosin right now in your eyes to
watch this video
my Osen can be thought of as tiny
molecular motors converting chemical
energy into mechanical energy the
swedish bio computer uses the myosin to
guide protein filaments along artificial
paths researcher Heine linker explains
quote in simple terms it involves
building a network of nano based
channels that give specific traffic
regulations for protein filaments the
solution in the network corresponds to
the answer of a mathematical question
and many molecules can find their way
through the network at the same time end
quote
so rather than having bulky computers
working in tandem performing multiple
simultaneous computations you have a
nano scale molecular motor doing the
same thing this means much smaller and
more powerful computers this bio
computer system is much easier and less
expensive to build than a quantum
computer mainly because some of the
crucial components that are found in
this computer are found in nature
the research team say that the bio
computers are likely to be a decade away
from production here's another quote
from the researcher linker quote the
fact of the molecules are very cheap and
that we have now shown that the bio
computers calculations work leads us to
believe that bio computers have the
prerequisites for practical use within
ten years
the research team also states that
existing programming algorithms can be
used on this system with some
optimization okay so we're almost at the
end of the video but let's quickly look
at the system in action you're looking
at it right now the numbers at the
bottom represent solves solutions to an
equation as you can see the system is
finding many solutions at the same time
so of course at the moment this system
looks a little slow and rudimentary but
this study was just a proof-of-concept
showing that the idea is sound allowing
researchers to have enough evidence to
foresee this being a viable alternative
to quantum computers
putting it another way this can be seen
as a Wright brothers moment in parallel
computing much like comparing that first
measly 450 meter flight that eventually
gave the feasible path for all modern
aircraft so what can we make of all of
this while quantum computing may be the
holy grail for the long run replacing
the operating realm of supercomputers
this proof of concept of a practical
easy to manufacture low-energy
low-cost parallel computing system may
mean that our desktops and future
laptops and even possibly smartphones
could see the power of what we call a
supercomputer today ultimately only time
will tell if this method truly becomes
all that the scientists and researchers
say it well but regardless it's going to
be an interesting decade for a final
further thought combining the former
with new scientific efforts on graphene
computing in which graphene transistors
are ready clocking 427 gigahertz
it looks like Moore's law could happily
live on for a while yet anyway that's
the end of the video thanks for watching
guys hopefully you could take something
away from that feel free to give this
video a thumbs up if you liked it
subscribe if you're new definitely do
that this has been to gogo you've been
watching cold fusion gears guys have a
good one and I'll catch you again soon
for the next video cold fusion is he
thinking
you